c'était une fois à nice même où je fais
un mac lire un petit papier quand on a
reçu
je ne sais pas combien de milliers
d'émigrés jeunesse du monde ont rappelé
les liens préférés
alors c'était là sur les monuments aux
morts c'est un homme avec une foule qui
venait depuis la burqa comme ça qu'on
sait tous que jusqu'à nice n'est ce pas
sur la route
et alors là et j'ai lui je sais pas moi
puisque c'est lui parce qu'il est très
court et c'était pas moi qui l'avait
créé 20 enfin c'est pendant ces quelques
mots choisis les plus grands succès y
paraît je ne sais pas combien ils ont un
talent 2 call moi je n'ai pas l'habitude
des paroles et des bases américaines
mais hier soir c'était fantastique je
vous regarde est au milieu de cette
salle immense vous étiez petit presque
perdu même si oui est-ce que vous avez
été quand même impressionné je fais je
vais te toucher décès de cette espèce de
sympathie amour je ne sais pas où amitié
qui est temps déjà mais porte justement
vous aimait beaucoup le mot amour pablo
picasso
oui même une jeune fille que nous avons
interviewé pour je ne sais pas quel jour
là je lui avais dit ça vous savez pour
voir que la bourbre vespa vous aimez
bien les gens j'aime vous pouvez faire
tout le monde aurait pas de sens c'est
pas que je dirais même un bouton de
porte n'est ce pas
un pot de chambre pourquoi est ce que
vous aimez la télévision aussi parce
qu'elle cherche allait bien mais je
commence quand je vois ce qu'avait le
mariage de la princesse margaret
et quelqu'un m'a prêté un appareil alors
eu la preuve révèle et j'ai continué
après que c'est ce qui serait formidable
quand on vous a devant les caméras de
télévision ce serait de vous laisser
tout seul en liberté vous seriez
tellement capable de faire des choses
formidables pour les téléspectateurs
vouloir inventorier les choses c'est
probablement cette fois des fois je
trouve des choses magnifiques à
l'interruption des choses toujours dit
que j'aime qui m'intéresse mais la foi
et c'est des fois des bois parce que
nous on est là tous les deux tout seul
ar non c'est pas vrai car la tour est ce
que si vous deviez choisir vous-même
l'époque la peinture la toile qui
devrait vous survivre est ce que quelle
serait cette toile qui serait d'abord il
s'en passait déficit s'est fait avec des
tentations tellement du moment de
l'époque
l'état dans lequel tout le monde et moi
nous trouvons qui c'est très difficile a
augmenté ganic a su fermer car c'était
une grande catastrophe même commencement
de beaucoup d'autres que nous avons sué
destin mais en france c'est exceptionnel
mais c'est faux ce sont des mémoires qu
on s'écrit soi même des cahiers
vous êtes extraordinairement jeune pablo
picasso est ce que vous pensez que moi
vous savez maubeuge
peut-être que c'est une jeune ici au
lieu dit notre dame de vie habite
picasso picasso et sa femme jacqueline
un document jamais vu picasso dans un de
ces ateliers de mougins
et jacques prévert a écrit un poème que
va nous dire yves montand